[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vu l'émission de débat et d'opinion de
préférence contradictoires de figaro
live comme chaque jour nous allons
traiter quatre sujets que nous avons
retenue dans l'actualité nous
commencerons par les conséquences
possibles du nouveau tir de missile
effectué hier par la corée du nord nous
allons nous en occuper a dit donald
trump qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça est
un petit peu sibyllin pour l'instant
nous reparlerons aussi du discours d'
emmanuel macron au burkina faso il
après un propos officiels il s'est
entretenu avec les étudiants de
l'université de ouagadougou avec un
style on va dire assez novateur que nous
commenterons et puis nous parlerons du
prix reçu par françois hollande le prix
de l'humour le grand prix 2010 est de
l'humour politique monsieur petites
blagues et des retours et enfin nous
parlerons de la grossophobie cette
discrimination en tout cas vécu comme
tel semble-t-il pour les personnes en
surpoids
la mairie de paris y consacre une
journée ce sera le 15 décembre une
journée de lutte
naturellement contre la grossophobie
nous allons parler de ces quatre sujets
avec benoît avait dit randy bonsoir vous
êtes d'historiens professeur en classes
préparatoires vous êtes un spécialiste
de l'espagne
vous avez d'ailleurs écrit une histoire
de l'espagne des guerres napoléoniennes
à nos jours
bonsoir charles beigbeder bonsoir vous
êtes entrepreneur hommes politiques vous
avez appartenu à l'ump dont vous avez
été exclu c'était moins fréquent à
l'époque qu'aujourd'hui c'était en 2013
parce que vous aviez présenter une liste
concurrente à celle de nathalie
kosciusko morizet à paris c'est aussi
actionnaire de l'un correct un jeune
confrère vous êtes voilà vous êtes
l'auteur du livre que nous avons vu trop
brièvement à l'écran charnellement de
france dont les très bons livres la
preuve c'est que vous l'avez écrit et
vous est aussi actionnaire de la
correcte nouveau mensuel on va dire de
la droite hors les murs mensuel de
réflexion qui consacre sa couverture ce
mois ci à l'art contemporain avec un
dossier assez percutant bonsoir alexis
lacroix vous seriez vous êtes directeur
délégué de la rédaction de l'express
contributeurs d'une autre revue qui
n'est pas exactement situé au même
endroit ça c'est
il n'en est pas moins intéressant ce qui
s'appelle la règle du jeu et votre
hebdomadaire l'express consacre cette
semaine sa couverture à la vérité sur
les vaccins nous allons si la joie
d'accueillir renaud girard le
chroniqueur international du figaro
conçoit renault voit vous êtes l'auteur
entre autres de quel diplomatie pour la
france prendre les réalités telles
qu'elles sont parus aux éditions du cerf
et bien international parlons-en
hier le régime nord coréen à tirer un
nouveau missile et la présentatrice
vedette de la chaîne cassée tv riche
faune y qu'on ne présente plus s'en est
réjoui vous allez voir est donc en train
de le cateau présence au procès ne
trouvait pas grâce à ses gains à la
radio a dit vianney son bouquet final
via rail au guidon d'une honda
voilà on ne s'en lasse pas renaud girard
sait c'est business as usual parce que
c'est pas le premier tir de missile
nord-coréen ou bien est-ce qu'on a
franchi un degré supplémentaire dans la
dans la tension
oui on a franchi un degré supplémentaire
parce que ce qui est important c'est que
kim jong-un donc le jeune dictateur
rocketman rocket man dans une pièce bien
qu'un dynasty
je suis couvert la corée du nord depuis
après la deuxième guerre mondiale donc
le petit fils a dit que la corée du nord
est est un état nucléaire capables de
parler d'égal à égal avec les états unis
puisqu'il savait cette dissuasion
intercontinental qui pouvait donc
projeté des missiles jusqu'au territoire
américain
mais comme
speakerine l'a bien dit que c'était en
fait pour servir la stabilité et la paix
dans le monde et il n'a pas assorti
cette fierté d'avoir l'armé nucléaire de
menace pour quiconque dans la région
mais directement quiconque attaquera les
intérêts de la colère donc c'est une
assurance vie je pense qu'à prix kim
jong-un est ce que je crois que donald
trump va faire quelque chose non je
crois que donald trump est un faux dur
je crois qu'il parle beaucoup il fait
peu a fondu ou un faux dur c'est des
gens qui agissent souvent parle très peu
et agissent lui parle beaucoup il twitte
beaucoup mais il agir assez peu assez
peu contre la chine la chine a pas
beaucoup avancer c'est ses positions en
mer de chu de chine méridionale sur les
petites îles au spart les et paracels et
c'est fait pl je pense je pense qu'il ne
fera strictement rien il ne peut rien
faire et donc c'est c'est aujourd'hui
nous fêtons un échec
stratosphérique de la stratégie
américaine depuis depuis 20 ans ils se
sont attaqués ils ont dépensé 1500
milliards de dollars en 2003 pour contre
un pays pour détruire disait-il les
armes de destruction massive qui
n'existait pas en irak mais ils ont
laissé se développer au même moment ses
armes de l'action massive en corée et
qui existent bel et bien et je vois pas
ce qu'il pourrait faire
la question clé de ministre andy c est
ce que ces armes c'est simplement une
arme de dissuasion après tout nous aussi
nous sommes une puissance nucléaire et
portant d'une agression personne ou bien
est ce que ou bien est-ce que le leader
nord coréen va s'en servir il ya que lui
qui peut le savoir mais il est clair qu
on est quand même dans une logique de
dissuasion
même si on s'est toujours beaucoup
interrogé sur l'âme j'ai dit à la
légitimité de la dissuasion rapporté au
régime qui le porte
mais on a eu des armes nucléaires pour
des régimes démocratiques les états unis
la france la grande bretagne et puis on
a eu
l'arme nucléaire pour l'union soviétique
or après tout ça quand même construit un
système des relations internationales
sur lequel on à tangente et sans doute
des moments un peu difficiles mais on a
malgré tout préserver préservé
l'essentiel des équilibres moi ce qui me
fera beaucoup dans cette affaire c'est
que alors là pour le coup c'est cette
prolifération nucléaire qui est
inquiétante
on a le quart en corée du nord on a sans
doute le pakistan l'iran allait annoncer
s'il en est car il allait faire plaisir
il ya douze démocratie alors que le
bombe atomique
israël bien sûr tylenol eyal humble et
puis il ya la paix qui n'est pas une
démocratie qu'il faut de gouverner par
l'armée comme on le voit encore
récemment qui est le pakistan qu'elle
abonde accueille alors mon équipe ce qui
m'inquiète c'est plutôt de penser quand
on regarde de façon globale le continent
asiatique qui vient de vivre trente
années de croissance économique
spectaculaire
j'ai ça me fait penser mais je fais des
parallèles avec tous les les
approximations que ça peut avoir à
l'europe de 1890 à 1914 et il y à un
surcroît d'énergie accumulée dans cette
région et il ya beaucoup
d'alsace-lorraine de balkan de systèmes
et voilà c'est ça qui est inquiétant
c'est à dire que on compte tout course
aux armements fini à un moment ou un
autre par déboucher sur un conflit qui
peut être un conflit majeur
et d'ailleurs ça semble inquiéter un
certain nombre de gens notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
valentin pilar du figaro.fr nous a
rejoint valentin la la la tendance sur
les réseaux c'est plutôt on va appeler
ça du pacifisme comme on voudra ou en
tout cas de la peur exactement en tout
cas quand on pose la question faut-il
frappé la corée du nord les réponses
faut le dire sont très contents sont
très contrastés sur sur twitter il ya
une certitude
l'inquiétude monte sur les réseaux quand
on pose la question le risque étant trop
gros sur l'eau selon eux c'est non voilà
il ne faut pas frappé la corée du nord
il ne chercherait qu'un prétexte pour
éclater une seconde guerre mondiale
prétend benalia sur twitter la
diplomatie d'abord la france doit jouer
le rôle de médiateur c'est le moment où
jamais de montrer que nous sommes le
pays des droits de l'homme suggère panda
toujours sur twitter
il fallait le faire dans les années 2000
quand c'était encore possible
aujourd'hui
si les américains frappent la corée du
nord elle répliquera sur le japon c'est
un point intéressant qui est soulevée
par gaulois renault vous êtes d'accord
si les américains frappent la corée du
nord
il peut y avoir des répercussions sur le
japon sur le jabot même sur la corée du
sud et la corée du sud où il ya trente
mille soldats américains postés en
permanence et donc je c'est pour ça que
je pense que jamais un président
américain prendra le risque parce que il
peut avoir si vous voulez trente mille
morts le lendemain
et donc je ne pense pas qu'il prendra le
risque de faire une attaque préventive
contre la corée du nord et puis en
stratégie chat échaudé craint l'eau
froide
les américains ont fait participer à
deux guerres préventives l'irak et la
libye récemment ce sont deux fiascos de
chaos partout et donc ça échaudé craint
l'eau froide je vois pas qu'il fasse une
troisième guerre préventive sans
attendre une solution à ce problème de
corée du nord mais j'aimerais rassurer
et quand même les internautes
les twittos ce qui vit qui vous ont
écrit parce que c'est pas parce qu'on a
la bombe h
ça c'est une certitude ils l'ont est un
vecteur en balistique que on maîtrise la
rentrée des têtes nucléaires dans
l'atmosphère dans les couches ou super
de l'atmosphère où les la coiffe peut
s'échauffer à quatre mille degrés
celsius et donc alors je fais lille
seront plus frais liés à ceux des haines
cette année ça ne fait pas de voir je
vous rassure un expert militaire ni
atomique mais oui mais je dirais
avant par mois d'écart avec bud et
ingénieurs ingénieur de l'école centrale
il est aussi auditeurs de l'institut des
hautes études de la défense quelques
discussions avec des ingénieurs et puis
des officiers de haut rang me font
comprendre enfin que la corée du nord ne
maîtrise pas encore
le missile balistique intercontinental
avec charges nucléaires
incorporé et il ya encore quelques mois
peut-être même des années avant qu'il
l'ait parce que c'est extrêmement
compliqué d'en profiter
profitons de cette phase pour tout faire
pour éviter qu'il est et donc mais et la
voix elle elle ne peut être que
diplomatiques avec la russie et la chine
bien entendu voilà les deux grandes
puissances régionales voilà c'est ce qui
est mis en avant par les internautes
c'est la diplomatie mais c'était aussi
l'occasion en fait pour beaucoup
d'internautes de rappeler que les
etats-unis la france ou d'autres pays
ont la banque duclair alors pourquoi pas
d'autres voilà au final c'est ça la
question
j'en profite et la prolifération ça
deviens moi je vais avoir une position
je reconnais que c'est facile sur un
plateau de télévision en france au
figaro avec guillaume roquette d'avoir
l'air d'être dans la surenchère mais je
pense qu'on ne peut pas comme vous
sembliez de suggérer aux benoît s'en
tenir à dire qu'au fond ce monsieur
jouerait à une forme de dissuasion aux
fonds classiques et même comme vous
l'avez fait je crois comparer cette
situation avec celle de la dissuasion
que nous connaissions lors de
l'affrontement des deux blocs car on est
justement dans un monde qui n'est plus
by pop bipolariser et donc de beaucoup
moins sûre que ne l'était paradoxalement
le monde de l'affrontement bipolaire
aujourd'hui dans ce monde que certains
géopoliticien des amis de renaud appel 0
polaire la prolifération est un problème
mais elle est un problème surtout quand
elle s'accompagne d'une forme de démence
car sans faire de jugement psychiatrique
à l'emporte-pièce sur kim hee kim jong
une seule absolument certain c'est que
cet homme là n'a pas toute sa raison ou
s'il il a une forme de raison c'est une
raison paranoïaque donc moi je crains je
ne dis pas que trump n'a pas raison de
reculer mais je crains personnellement
la puissance de dévastation assez
considérable d'une telle puissance
nucléaire à partir du moment où elle est
dirigé par un tyran sanguinaire car on
le rappellera jamais assez il ya une
distinction absolument essentiel à faire
entre les régimes démocratiques quand
ils possèdent la bombe atomique
effectivement il se limite
une forme de dissuasion classiques et
des régimes qui sont des tyrannies qui
sont des tyrannies despotique ou
totalitaires ou en tout cas plus ou
moins les 2 chez qu'il n'y a pas de
limite et c'est cette absence de limites
qui à mon avis fait qu'on ne saurait à
mon avis trop se rassurer à bon compte
comme un certain nombre de chefs d'état
essayent de nous ont persuadé à mon avis
on est en train de préparer
si vous voulez peut-être d'ailleurs sur
la durée mais une situation de type
munichois voilà chaud que je crois qu'on
est en train de reculer
on est en train de perdre chacune des
occasions possibles de définitivement
anéantir cette menace est passée la
corée je n'ai pas dis ça je dis qu'il
est facile
donc j'ai dit qu'il va faire j'ai dit
lundi qu'il n'est pas facile depuis un
studio de télévision d'avoir l'air de
faire la leçon aux dirigeants de ce
monde et donc j'ai bien conscience que
ici avec le ministère du verbe c'est
très facile d'avoir l'air d'afficher des
positions guerrières ou va-t-en guerre
donc je ne leur ferai pas la leçon pour
autant la position pacifiste qui semble
être celle de la communauté
internationale et notamment notre
président ne me paraît pas tout à fait
convaincante face à la réalité si vous
voulez tout à fait nouvelle de ce type
de menace quand on a un tyran
sanguinaire qui est un moyen de
destruction aussi grand franchement il
faut quand même penser à l'arrêter voilà
en france même si on sait pas très bien
quoi faire à l'entraînement donc en tout
cas c'est l'occasion pour vous donner
les points de vue des internautes et au
delà du fait que personne ne veuille la
guerre la tonalité sur twitter se résume
au final à celle d'un agacement lorsque
les états unis ou encore la france se
permet de donner des leçons de
diplomatie et là les internautes en fait
cite le cas de l'irak la syrie de la
libye et de ses interventions
alors y at il une solution concernant
cette escalade de la crise voici celle
de kohl's internautes du figaro.fr que
les chinois impose un blocus total à la
corée du nord et kim jong-hun se calmera
peut-être merci valente a en tout cas il
faut l'espérer
et vous parlez des internautes du figaro
ils sont aussi assez partagés puisque la
question du jour faut-il intervenir
militairement contre la corée du nord
départage quasiment à 50 50 avec une
toute petite majorité pour le non les
points de vue le paradoxe quand même
charles beigbeder on cette histoire
c'est que on a l'impression que c'est
rome qui est qui est plus au moins
autant va-t-en guerre
que kim jong-un comme s'il y avait on
les renvoyer dos à dos l'ebit s'est
décrédibilisé par ce que il a fait des
rodomontades guerrière martial et puis
et puis ensuite il ne fait rien donc
c'est exactement le contraire de ce
qu'il faut faire dans ces cas là il faut
dire peu et agir comme le dit comme
richelieu savait le faire
la grande époque et en envoyant ses
tueurs mais là franchement on est on est
dans une situation où trump s'est
affaiblie alors ils étaient jeunes il
faut dire aussi je pense quand même que
on a construit le système médiatique a
construit une image de trump qui est
quand même très très fausse et on met
côte à côte et en parallèle kim jong-il
et et trump
alors que l'un est complètement ficelé
par un système institutionnel avec quand
même tu pouvoir qui ce qui équilibre qui
se contrôle qui ce qui se balance et au
contraire de l'autre côté effectivement
une tyrannie familiale donc il faut
faire attention même si je partage
complètement le diagnostic sur le
caractère imprévisible et déroutant de
la présidence trump mais les états unis
ont quand même un système d'assurance
institutionnel qui permet de penser que
le jour où une décision sera prise elle
sera quand même construire le 10 autres
rapidement le renvoi dos zadoù que
certains pratiquent pas pas ici pas sur
ce plateau
il renvoie dos à dos du président
américain et du tyran nord-coréen à
quelque chose d'attirant et de
scandaleuses ces cd réalisé
vous regrettez il faut répéter le pays
qu'on a fait un accord qui est très
important le 14 juin 2015 ou le lire on
a renoncé volontairement à
l'enrichissement de l'uranium à faire un
programme militaire et que pour des
raisons électoralistes et de ses
relations avec le congrès trump veut
dénoncer les engagements qui ont été
pris aux termes de cet accord par c'est
très dangereux soeur merci
il beaucoup il ya un autre chef d'état
qui parle beaucoup c'est le nôtre
emmanuel macron il était au burkina faso
hier et il a eu un échange ma foi dans
un style assez nouveau avec les
étudiants réunis à l'université de
ouagadougou
en voici quelques morceaux choisis vous
m'avez parlé comme si j'étais le
président du burkina faso
quelque part vous me parlez comme si
j'étais toujours une puissance coloniale
mais moi je ne veux pas m'occuper
d'électricité dans les universités
c'est le travail c'est le travail du
président
alors par contre alors par contre je
vous rassure
du coup il s'en va installer
du coup ils partirent et réparer la
climatisation
voilà tout ça tient peut-être au temps
du stand-up que du discours présidentiel
ça peut plaire peut pas tout le monde
écoutez ce qu'en disait ce matin le
président de debout la france nicolas
dupont-aignan sur europe 1 si un homme
de droite où le président sarkozy ou
donald trump avait s'était comporté au
burkina faso comme emmanuel macron toute
la presse ce matin ne parlerai que de ça
il a été d'une arrogance
j'allais dire d'une violence à l'égard
des autorités du burkina faso à la
limite du racisme et et moi je ne
l'acceptent pas et estime qu'un chef
d'état ne peut pas se comporter comme ça
avec les varois écoutez j'ai du respect
et de la considération pour nicolas
dupont aignan grand spa lé non mais non
non non non je le dis en face est un
homme de conviction il défend une option
gaulle aux souverainistes avec un
certain panache mais car non mais car il
car il le fait dans la solitude et c'est
vrai dans une situation de minorité
médiatique
donc je n'ai pas envie de le critiquer
plus que plus que de raison et puis par
ailleurs il sert aussi de paratonnerre à
des électeurs qui va être tentée par
marine le pen mais qui au fond peuvent
trouver chez lui un asile plutôt que
d'aller vers l'extrême droite donc pour
toutes ces raisons les sons le existé
mais en moins là je crois qu'il fait une
mauvaise analyse il fait une mauvaise
analyse du discours de macron quand on
est un petit peu disons réceptif
quant à une deuxième oreille politique
ce qu'on entend dans le discours de
macron je crois très sincèrement c'est
celle inverse exacte de la condé de
condescendance néocolonial du france
afrique
c'est au contraire un discours de
responsabilité il parle ici à des
adultes ce sont peut-être des étudiants
il leur parle en adule il leur dit c'est
fini le temps où effectivement il y
avait cette espèce d'ingérence malsaine
aux limites aux contours mal définis est
terminée et donc il le dit sur un ton
plus humoristique qui crée une
complicité qui est tout à fait réel avec
ses avec les locuteurs avec qui il est
donc tout ça n'est absolument pas dans
le registre de la condescendance et
c'est plutôt du côté d'une sorte de
clarification bien tardive je reconnais
de la relation entre la france et des ex
puissance coloniale qui lui étaient
vassaliser donc je pense que de ce point
de vue là qu'on peut trouver à redire
à plein de choses sans doute dans ce
long discours en partie improvisé mais
de ce point de vue là dupont aignan à
tort la prestation de macron le discours
de ouagadougou restera comme une des
bases non attendez comme une des belles
de la relation des franco africaines
alors que le discours de dakar prononcé
il ya dix ans par nicolas sarkozy était
resté comme une sorte de voile comme une
sorte d' ombre dans la relation entre la
france et la suisse y aller qu'il
accroche précise qu'il n'y a pas que
debout la france et dupont aignan qui
était critique puisque la france
insoumise a fait part d'un communiqué
critiquant la position néocolonialistes
et l'attitude méprisante du président
public s'il accroît votre nom mais sur
la blagounette sur la blagounette
d'abord c'est une blague
c'était il ya rien de déplacé ensuite ça
passe très bien au burkina faso donc
franchement
arrêtons de polémiquer et cessons de
nous indigner à la moindre boutade d'un
homme politique et en particulier du
président avaient franchement les
critiques là de nicolas dupont aignan
jean luc mélenchon je crois nicolas bay
également sont tout à fait déplacée sur
le fond déjà sur quelque chose de
nouveau dans la politique africaine de
la france avec ce voyage où il ya juste
eu ses moments de télévision assez
réjouissant je crois qu'à une
clarification il ya effectivement pas du
tout de racisme j'ai aussi du respect
pour le courage de nicolas dupont aignan
je ne partage pas les opinions parce que
moi je suis favorable à la construction
européenne mais mais là je pense qu'ils
se trompent
actuellement j a absolument rien de
raciste les propos d' emmanuel macron je
ne pense pas du tout que qu'il soit
raciste il veut assez clairement tourné
la page
voilà est-ce que les prédécesseurs est
ce que foccart et et condescendant à
l'égard des dirigeants africains je suis
cachée du général de volvo cars à la
croix qu'il les respecte et je crois
qu'il aime l afrique et que et que
évidemment je ne vais sûrement pas tout
jeter à la rivière de ce que la france a
fait pendant la colonisation parce qu'il
a fait beaucoup évidemment et même après
je connais les crimes de la colonisation
là dessus oui c'est toujours cette
repentance permanente
voilà qui vous conviendrait valoriser
les apports de la colonisation en tout
cas d'avoir un débat équilibré au
burkina faso haute volta à l'époque il
n'y a pas eu de crime de colonisation il
ya peut-être égide a parlé il ya
peut-être eu au congo-b au congo belle
sûrement est peut-être un peu aussi au
congo français des cordes et des corvées
obligatoire et c'est dans la
construction des lignes de chemin de fer
mais en afrique thouars non la
collection est une oeuvre qui a coûté
très cher à la france et qui a construit
sa venant de brazza c'est vraiment un
humanitaire si vous voulez bon voilà il
faut donc on peut être tout à fait fière
de la colonisation française qui a coûté
très cher au pays c'est à dire pour ça
que de gaulle lâche l'afrique noire que
ça coûtait très cher voilà mais je
trouve que macron voilà tourner la page
parle avec humour pourquoi pas général
de gaulle lui-même que qu'elle lui
monsieur dupont aignan avaient d'humour
c'est qu'on ait des morts c'est le fait
de mon inexpérience vous avez lu ça dans
une
dans une conférence de presse bon et
bien le prétendre on a le droit
d'utiliser de l'humour je le trouve pas
déplacés et je trouve qu'il ya
visiblement quelque chose qui est passé
en fait entre emmanuel macron à la
jeunesse africaine
et tant mieux et cette phrase que vous
avez cités d'excellentes ce n'est pas
moi qui gère le burkina faso les choses
sont claires c'est pas moi qui le
finance non plus benoît pellistrandi moi
je pense que là le lac et sur la
colonisation doit vraiment la purger
parce que c'est absurde d'être là avec
des événements qui remontent à il ya 100
ans ou plus le véritable enjeu c'est la
décolonisation
c'est à dire c'est la création d'un
espace politique marquée par des
frontières là où auparavant il y avait
une unité notamment une intégration
économique et régional et ça c'est le
président abdou diouf qu'il faisait
remarquer l'économie de l'afrique
occidentale française était beaucoup
plus intégré que l'économie actuelle
donc il faudrait travailler acea
ces faits là je crains cependant que le
discours du président macron ce qui est
par ailleurs très très remarquable sur
son fond mais ce soit aussi une manière
de masquer les faiblesses structurelles
de la france qui a de moins en moins les
moyens de peser en afrique et on le voit
on est militairement présent et de façon
décisive et que si on se retirer de ces
endroits se serait sans doute le chaos
donc il y a un savoir-faire français
qu'il faut absolument maintenir mais
c'est vrai que nous le portons dans un
cadre de disette budgétaire qui pèse
énormément et il lui faudra quand même
un jour admettre que la france n'est
plus complètement une puissance mondiale
et il faut définir des priorités
donc je pense que la difficulté du
présent macron c'est que tout le monde à
cette statue du commandeur qui est le
général de gaulle le fondateur de la
vème république et on veut absolument
continuer à faire comme lui il faut
inventer et donc je trouve qu'il
faudrait effectivement tourné la page de
la colonisation et inventer avec les
africains
ce que doit être l'avenir surtout quand
on voit en plus les perspectives
démographiques qui sont spectaculaires
mais charles beigbeder quand le
président a un public dit il n'y a plus
de politique africaine de la france
est ce que c'est vraiment un progrès non
mais il n'ya plus au sens au sens de la
politique de de grand papa et du temps
de l'udf et la françafrique mais mais
mais il faut une politique française
active en afrique bien sûr et d'ailleurs
c'est bien qu'il ait parlé d'immigration
et des flux migratoires qui qu'il faut
absolument limiter
il l'a dit devant
les étudiants du burkina et ça c'était
important parce que il a été clair il ne
pourra pas accueillir toute cette
jeunesse en europe et en france
oui vous êtes bienvenu pour vos études
mais ne pourront pas vous garder
durablement sa sollicitude je pense que
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'essentiel
parce qu'il faut voir la manière dont on
traite ce qui est vrai que les futures
élites de ces pays là or il faut
vraiment que quand ils viennent en
france vers leurs études
on les soigne pour qu'ils soient ensuite
des relais d'influencé de la france dans
leur pays en raison de la disette
budgétaire notamment dans nos armées
parce qu'on m'a dit récemment que dans
les promotions de saint cyr il ya trente
ans il y avait trente stagiaires
africains et aujourd'hui on n'a plus que
12 parce qu'on a plus les moyens
et on aura compté aussi l'histoire de
nos colonel sénégalais qui allaient
faire leur école de guerre en chine
parce que la france a bien aimé la
gueule et c'est vrai une politique d'
influence et et que l'armée c'est très
important en afrique pour un pont pour
maintenir maintenir l'ordre des
territoires immenses et c'est vrai que
cette politique de coopération mythique
de formation les officiers africains par
les écoles françaises a été a été
excellent et aliments qu'il faudrait
et ces fonds de pme africaines qui a été
annoncé donc avec plus d'un milliard
d'euros de capitaux ça s'est très bien
passé pour aider les entrepreneurs
afrique les d'investissement je laisse
le dernier mot sur ce sujet aux
internautes marion qui est d'accord avec
alexis j'imagine c'est alexis lacroix
puisque d'accord mais apparemment elle
vous connaît d'autant plus que pour une
fois on a un président dynamique et qui
a un certain talent oratoire alors que
jamal considère lui au contraire qu' il
y à de l'arrogance dans l'attitude
présidentielle il ya un autre président
pas c'est celui là qui n'est vraiment
pas arrogant c'est françois hollande
l'ancien chef de l'état a reçu hier le
grand prix 2010 est de l'humour
politique et il en a profité pour en
refaire de l'humour
regardez je prends conscience qu'un
hommage donc b rendu il était temps je
suis bien compris que c'était l'ensemble
de mon oeuvre qui étaient salués ce soit
de ce domaine là mais je vais ici vous
faire une révélation
mon oeuvre n'est pas achevée au moins
sur ce plan là merci voilà monsieur
petites blagues est de retour ce qui est
une bonne nouvelle va sûrement pour
dérider les plateaux de télévision mais
est ce que tout ça est très présidentiel
regarder l'attitude quand même un peu
gêné de stéphane le foll qui est l'un
des derniers soutiens de françois
hollande l'ancien ministre il était ce
matin sur france info
pour s'est toujours distinguée avec
beaucoup d'humour et beaucoup d'esprits
pas vous que je vais le dire vous le
savez tous mais est-ce que ça n'est pas
un problème d'être qu'on ramène françois
hollande après un quinquennat plutôt à
sa 14e est ce que c'est votre problème
est un problème c'est à nous de
d'expliquer ce qui a été fait et un jour
il y aura aussi à s'expliquer sur ce
qu'il a fait
et tu vas cran voilà c'est un peu est ce
qu'il sait très présidentiel ces
attitudes de france aux noms mais je
peux ajouter je pense qu'il faut il faut
toujours partir pour comprendre ce type
de dison de l'échappée solitaire qui lui
est coutumière il faut partir de son
ressenti ce que le prêt de l'ancien
président république ressent vraiment
très intimement au delà des postures et
de son cynisme il ressent une injustice
il se dit j'ai été mais jugé sur mon
bilan est donc toutes les
les occasions de se rattraper doivent
mettre offerte par par le l'actualité et
donc c'est vrai que cette manière de
prendre à la rigolade
c'est une façon de dire on va voir ce
qu'on va voir je n'ai pas dit mon
dernier mot
ça vous voyez c'est le premier niveau
d'interprétation le deuxième il est plus
problématique c'est à dire que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la reconstruction
éventuelle du parti socialiste elle est
empêché par ce type d'intervention et
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans les
images que vous venez de montrer le foll
se montre tellement embêté car c'est au
fond pour reprendre le titre d'un livre
célèbre 68 c'est un héritage impossible
pour eux surtout pour le foll qui est en
attente qui est actuellement dans la
compétition face à najat vallaud
belkacem pour reprendre le parti c'est
impossible pour eux de se positionner
face à cet héritage là et donc on peut
penser qu'au delà si vous voulez de sa
déception de ne pas être reconnus à la
hauteur des réalisations réels
d'ailleurs de ce quinquennat il y en a
eu il ya de la part de françois hollande
aussi une démarche si vous voulez plus
ambigu peut-être même plus perverse qui
consiste à casser la baraque de ses amis
socialistes aujourd'hui avec ce type
d'intervention intempestives
mais ça va éviter la comparaison entre
les deux présidents dont à
l'intervention d' emmanuel macron et
celle de françois hollande certes ce
n'est pas dans le même quart mais c'est
quand même un peu un peu cruel pour
l'ancien nom bon alors je ne suis pas
politologue c'est pourquoi je ne me suis
pas sûr je vais pouvoir être très long
sur ce sujet pour marty plus
présidentiel que l'autre quelque chose
autrement
bah oui ben hollande
il n'a pas su être président de la
république l'histoire l'a montré
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est un type
sympa comme on vient de le voir c'est un
type de rôle qui est capable
d'autodérision et maintenant est ce que
est ce qu'un président de la république
ça doit être un mec sympa c'est la
question non je suis pas sûr c'est
quelqu'un qui doit gouverner et il a
échoué après l'histoire écrivait valeur
ça lui a pas réussi
il a échoué la presse qu'il était sain
passé il a échoué parce que la politique
mise en oeuvre n'était pas bonne ça n'a
pas produit de résultats il aurait pu
réussir tout en étant sympa je veux dire
je crois que là que les français lui en
ont voulu ne pas être assez présidentiel
d'avoir voulu être comme tout le monde
oui mais il n'a pas été assez
présidentiel parce que dès le début il a
jamais eu le courage de dire les choses
telles qu'elles étaient mal je reste
convaincu que il avait deux options
c'est-à-dire être un petit françois
mitterrand ce qui n'a même pas réussi à
être ou être un pierre mendès france
il aurait pu jouer la carte en 2012
c'est c'était dur et évocateur du
réformateur du réformateur courageux
reprenant les idées de gauche mais les
modernisant le se présentant comme
adepte de la gestion il en était
rigoureusement un cas pas mais je pense
que ça c'est encore plus profond mais je
serai encore plus sévère je pense que
même si tout le milieu parisien vente
les la grande intelligence de l'ancien
président hollande
moi je reste convaincu qu'il ya une
limite à cette intelligence aussi je
pense que si moi aussi je suis vraiment
effectivement j'ai jamais vraiment senti
très président de la france alors qu'on
sent que emmanuel macron et président de
la france c'est assez consternant
la passion dévorante l'obsession ce
pauvre françois hollande pour les médias
et la passe et viletta peut occuper
normalement comme présent république
on a vu qu'il avait eu 75 entretien en
tête à tête avec des journalistes du
monde qui ensuite ont fait livre
ravageur sur lui voit où il a délivré au
passage des secrets d'un président ne
devrait pas dire au revoir à 2 à naples
et dans leur évasion et la n'apporte
qu'une petite émission qui lui est tendu
n'était
n'importe quel micro il peut pas
s'empêcher de sauter dessus et de ne pas
garder une certaine
voilà ce petit prix de l'humour
politique bon les les journaux en
parlent beaucoup mais en face est quand
même rien va jouer si vous voulez c'est
si je peux juste récépissé petit rythme
viable il ferait peut-être mieux
effectivement de d'essayer de défendre
son bilan peut-être d'écrire ses
mémoires
alors quoi et de réfléchir à l'avenir de
son annexe i am legend et l'ancien
président
je suis pas là uniquement pour le
défendre je pense que vous avez raison
vous mettez le doigt sur l'essentiel ses
mémoires en tout cas ses mémoires du
quinquennat il est en train d écrire et
c'est d'ailleurs un des événements
éditoriaux renault qui est annoncé pour
le mois de mai prochain semble-t-il dont
il y aura il y aura il y aura un livre
vérité de hollande sur son action comme
président de la république alors par
ailleurs ce que vous dites sur son
obsession des médias gelé noté moi aussi
et j'ai lu d'ailleurs un autre livre de
témoignages à l'intérieur si les mb dead
à l'intérieur du quinquennat qui est le
livre de son ancien conseiller en
communication le traite désormais
célèbre gaspard gander donc c'est
évidemment un livre pro domo et
désertique est un sport de convois la
liste indique pronovost il défend le
président enfin l'ancien président c'est
évident ils sont amis enfin ça se sent
néanmoins il ya une chose intéressante
dans le livre c'est que il apparaît
qu'une des erreurs de perspective qu'a
fait hollande
concernant les médias sur la nécessité
sept sur présence médiatique permanent
de ce clause contact permanent avec les
français c'est que ces gaspard ganzer
qui en est responsable
car c'est lui qui lorsqu'il arrive à
l'élysée lui dit président vous avez un
problème d'image
on va restaurer votre image notamment
via les réseaux sociaux en direction de
l'électorat le plus jeune donc hollande
a été embarqué dans cette stratégie qui
a peut-être des rpi et ses fruits sur le
plan de la de la popularité
le problème n'est pas là mais nous oui
mais qu'il a dès qu'il a des
verticaliser alors le problème
j'ouvre la télévision et je vais écouter
le président de la république
et qu'est-ce qui m'a dit ce président il
avait des gendarmes autour de lui il a
dit il m'a dit se donner la télévision
on a retrouvé la boîte noire oui mais il
suffisait qu'il y avait eu un crash
d'avion et que en fait intel à son
préfet ou un capitaine de gendarmerie
on a retrouvé ses les segments en amont
ces mots n'étaient pas sur wii par les
micros être compris c'est l'essai il
s'est laissé des verticaliser ça ne vous
avez raison sur ce plan mais justement
la responsabilité c'est pas là c'est pas
la sienne c'est ce qu'on lui a conseillé
de faire un tonneau et a même pas écouté
non non non c'est dément lui a conseillé
une stratégie de communication
médiatique on sait quand vous donne
aussi vous n'êtes pas forcément moi je
suis consterné par la qualité des livres
qui sortent sur le quinquennat hollande
tous ses conseillers de à kevin o morel
agathe marc gander et que ça ils sont
d'une discussion vide
il raconte un système complètement
fermés sur eux-mêmes ou leurs horizons
c'était le milieu médiatique c'est tout
ils ont oublié la france pendant qu'il
gouvernait et comment un plein de la
république peut garder son conseiller en
communication
quand il est à 20% dans les sondages
mitterrand avait vidé son conseiller
avait appelé pillant quand il y avait le
feu à la baraque à l'époque c'était
c'était 38 ou 40 pour dire la vérité il
en a changé il y avait claude sérillon
au milieu du monde à ils en changent il
fait venir gaspard compteur qui lui
conseille de s'adresser aux jeunes via
les réseaux sociaux
mais ça y est je suis un bon moment et
j'ai le sentiment quand même que là ils
sont pris et si vous annoncez
effectivement les mémoires de hollande
déjà au moins deux mais je trouve que
c'est spectaculaire le livre sera
forcément major d'être d'être aussi
brutale mais forcément nul parce que
s'il prend pas un peu de recul
s'il ne l'écrit pas lui même s'il le
fait écrire on sait bien comment ces
séjours seront là on s'improvise pas
écrivain c'est pas de gaulle quand même
donc je pense qu'il faudrait laisser des
camps des gens parce que il est clair
que quand on gouverne 50 ou n'est pas
rater tout n'est pas réussi certes mais
tout n'est pas rater il ya des choses
l'intervention il ya des choses et
choisit donc il faut laisser un peu
quand même
on revient pas comme ça se forme la et
un ancien président de la république
devrait avoir un minimum de dignité
le prix du mot politique c'est en
général très drôle mais là il aurait dû
conduire et solives ce livre on l'a
fallu ne le jugeons pas vendre
c'est visiblement ce n'est celle
hautement visible lors vous emporter la
contre ce pauvre françois hollande
visiblement c'est une réflexion de fond
sur la france il y aura forcément des
flashbacks des retours sur expérience
mais je ne crois pas que ça soit si vous
voulez des livres trou de serrure c'est
pas le genre de françois hollande et
nous espérons toyas j'aurais préféré
qu'il le fasse avant nous espérons que
ce livre espérons que le rite du
présidentiable dans une salle de bain de
démentir à hugo qui nous dit il n'a
jamais enfilé le costume de président il
restera dans l'histoire comme un
président par erreur charles beigbeder
peut-être qu'il faisait d'autant plus de
communication que il réforme est
finalement assez peu et que donc il
fallait bien remplir l'espace bien sûr
et toutes façons n'oublions pas qu'il a
été
je plus 10 15 ans premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste que c'est donc un
socialiste type qui veut toujours faire
la synthèse et ils ne savaient pas à
prendre de décision à relief
il a commencé son quinquennat avec des
messages très contradictoires et à part
l'opération verbard can au mali mme que
je saluais dans tous les sujets on a
régressé on a perdu même temps déjà pour
les entreprises le patron que lang le
chef d'entreprise que vous êtes pour les
entreprises mais où souvenez on sent que
ça va commencer à la fin du quinquennat
de sarkozy n'y allais les hausses
d'impôts mais lui il les a augmentées en
encore plus ça a été un coup autres un
très mauvais moment l effet à l'économie
française
on sait qu'ils croulent sous les
prélèvements obligatoires est
malheureusement d'ailleurs il ne baisse
pas avec m et cette usine à gaz qui l'a
mis en place n'a été profitable aux très
grands groupes qui se sont deux façons
sont mondialisés oui et il n'a
absolument pas su encourager ce qui doit
être encouragée en france bien
l'entrepreneuriat et l'épée le sabre
absolument
je vous propose de parler d'un nouveau
mot ça s'appelle la grossophobie la
grossophobie c'est la discrimination
contre les personnes en surpoids et bien
la mairie de paris a décidé d'organiser
le 15 décembre prochain une journée de
lutte contre la grossophobie ça se fait
à l'initiative d'une élue communiste de
la mairie de paris hélène bidard qu'ils
en aient ouvert hier en disant la lutte
contre la grossophobie est une grande
absente de la lutte contre les
discriminations alexis la quadra
conviennent 10 secondes sur ce ce besoin
qu'à notre époque de créer sans cesse de
nouvelles catégories de victimes
alors c'est sûrement justifier il ya
sûrement des gens qui s'est lancé il est
rond c'est inhérent à ce qu'on peut
appeler sur un plomb disons
philosophiques comme n'étant pas
simplement un phénomène sociétal le
politiquement correct
après tout c'est mais c'est vrai sur les
campus américains dans les années 80 la
faveur du différentialisme disons ethno
racial on a voulu réparer les mémoires
blessées des peuples qui avait été
victime des processus de colonisation et
notamment de l'une des plus atroces
d'entre elles la colonisation de
l'amérique donc il y avait ces
politiques de rattrapage qui n'était pas
simplement des politiques sociaux
économiques mais qui était aussi des
politiques culturelles de réévaluation
des mémoires blessées
je vais vous dire sur le sur le fond
c'est formidable c'est à dire que ont
toutes grandes démocraties je crois
devrait s'enorgueillir de réparer les
mémoires blessées des peuples qu'elle a
blessé ou des minorités qui en son sein
ont été blessés par la majorité ou ceni
mais c'est mais aujourd'hui la brée il
ya un mais nous vivons je crois une
dérive de ce bon politiquement correct
avec les effectivement la création
thibout les deux catégories de
sous-catégories victimaire qui en fait
je crois n'en sont pas alors bien sûr
que les personnes en surpoids doivent
être aidés dans leur accès il faut
qu'elles puissent accéder à votre studio
de télévision quand elle le camp vous
les invitez tout ça est une évidence
mais en revanche lancé une campagne
contre la grossophobie on hésite très
sincèrement on hésite entre le
ricanement le sourire et peut-être aussi
une forme de stupéfaction car c'est vrai
c'est très très loin on est très très
loin
des politiques de réparation des années
80 qui avaient leur justesse et qui
avaient leur bien fondé
le ministre a dit votre avis moyenne en
dégoûtant tout ça c'est que la
sécularisation nous a fait perdre
quelque chose qui existe des exemples et
la charité chrétienne et qui était la
capacité à avoir un regard sur les êtres
qui allait sur leur dignité et pas sur
effectivement leur définition physique
sexuelle ensuite idéologico politique et
je pense que tout ça c'est le trouble de
notre époque qui ne sait plus à quelle à
quels repères ce ce essayé de pousser
c'est le pouvoir politique est obligé
mais bien dans cette charité à la presse
des gens qui on a aidé voyez que la la
la la question religieuse à avoir on
parle bien de la maire de paris comme
notre dame
notre drame de paris c'est parce que
elle a quand même maintenant une
ambition ce sont des gens qui veulent
recomposer la société sur la base de
valeurs effectivement qui repose sur le
politiquement correct
oubliant que ce n'est pas au pouvoir
politique d'imposer les valeurs c'est la
société génère elle-même ses propres
comportements
alors je veux dire y'a rien de choquant
effectivement à alerter l'opinion
publique sur le fait que nos
comportements ne doivent pas être
discriminant mais il ya un côté
absolument caricaturale de la politique
de la mairie de paris mais j'aurais pas
prendre le rôle dans la manière dont
effectivement et elle est devenue 7,7
mérite paris vraiment une sorte de
caisse de résonance du tout et n'importe
quoi la parole est aux conseillers
d'arrondissement de paris charles
beigbeder je pense que elle pourrait
organisé par madame hidalgo la maire de
paris organise et peut-être une journée
contre l'hidalgo phobie après celui sur
la grossophobie seriez peut-être sais
pas si c'est possible mais c'est
insupportable de vouloir absolument
sectorisé le peuple entend toutes ces
catégories
d'ailleurs il manque une catégorie je
vais être paradoxal la catégorie dont il
a fait la couv de notre magazine
culturel et politique l'incorrect c'est
à dire le mâle blanc
le mâle blanc hétérosexuel qui fument
parfois un cia qui aime bien le jean ou
le whisky
kartcom qui nous sortent j'ai passé à
l'électrique faut se garer gratuitement
mais donc c'est vrai je vais crier moi
aussi j'en ai marre de là je suis contre
je suis pour qu'un colloque organisé
contre la grand mâle blanc phobie j'ai
aussi une fausse et opinions là dessus
en fait j'ai une proposition est une
opinion
la proposition c'est que je voudrais
créer la chaux vos phobies parce que des
sommes de chaud ici et qu'on apprend
très vite qu'aucun équipement
lorsque nous allons sortir nous allons
avoir à la tête
et la deuxième chose elle est la
deuxième chute je l'avais très bien dit
c'est qu'en fait on demande tout aux
pouvoirs publics mais c'est pas aux
pouvoirs publics effectivement à nous
apprendre la politesse à courtoisie la
charité chrétienne une vieille tradition
chrétienne dans ce pays et c'est pas non
plus d'ailleurs à l'état de dire comment
on parle la langue française est une
institution qui est là depuis richelieu
l'académie française outre jours oui il
y avait une une sénateurs jeudi madame
le sénateur
il y avait alors elle était un peu comme
ça choque et j'ai pu j'ai pas dis madame
la sénatrice vanier envoyé à côté vous
avez il y avait le rabbin delphine
horvilleur je vais pas dire madame la
rabine
je veux dire madame laura bas d'accord
dont je dis madame le rabbin je dis
madame le sénateur parce que je préfère
parler français mais c'est pas monsieur
jospin ou c'est pas à l'état à me dire
comment il faut que je parle ma langue
française et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
sorte d'appel à l'état systématique
d'appel aux autorités publiques qui est
dramatique j'ai connu les communistes
dame
j'ai connu un parti communiste dans ma
jeunesse qui avait n'était pas du tout
communiste moi j'étais gaullisme et qui
avait beaucoup plus d'alluré me souviens
qu'il verra là rené andrieu qui valait
les élus autour des fêtes c'était autre
chose vous très vite parce que si vous
avez raconté
votre jeunesse qui dépasse et loire avec
la croix en ternois grosse la
grossophobie vous avez compris que ma
position était quand même plutôt
critique de l'initiative néanmoins cette
obsession envers une minorité de victime
je veux courir la récente d'un
internaute
n'est ce pas une sorte de mode ou de
calculs politiques chez madame hidalgo
alors je crois que on se trompe
justement c'est ça que je voulais dire
je crois qu a imputé la responsabilité
de ce type de campagne à une sorte de
calcul politique de madame le maire de
paris c'est une erreur car vous c'est
faire fi d'une partie de son entourage
il y a si vous voulez parmi les 200
conseillers en communication
non mais attendez sens et vous continuez
un phrase si je peux continuer ma phrase
c'est faire fi d'une partie de son
entourage politique qui est en ces
matières là sur des positions beaucoup
plus arrêté beaucoup plus définitif est
probablement beaucoup plus sectaires que
les siennes je ne crois pas je le dis
très sincèrement pour la connaître un
peu que anne hidalgo donne dans cette
caricature du politiquement correct
en revanche il y a au sein de la mairie
de paris des personnes donc c'est la
ligne 1 donc il faudrait au lieu de la
critiquer comme l'ont fait et routier
dans un livre qui est par ailleurs un
tissu de d'insanités il vaudrait mieux
si vous voulez faire la distinction
entre le maire de paris et une partie de
son entourage qui effectivement donne
dans le politiquement correct le plus le
plus effréné il ya de la surenchère à la
mairie de paris charles beigbeder à côté
je comprends pas c'est comme anne
hidalgo qui nomme ses conseillers qui
nomme son entourage qui choisit ses
adjoints et c'est cette paire cette
communication permanente boc qui datent
de delanoë
c'est à dire qu'elle est la digne
héritière de dépenses combien d impôt de
pétrole magnifique qui commence à
couteaux en millions de m2 acheté 200
personnes dédiée à la communication
du maire de paris de la maire de paris
je sais plus comment dire c'est délirant
la ville de la ville de paris c'est 70
mille fonctionnaires pour dominion deux
cent mille habitants
le grand londres ils ont quatre fois
moins de fonctionnaires pour 1000
habitants
donc il ya un moment il va falloir se
poser la question qui fonctionne la
gestion de nombreux de ce machin
et puis c'est 400 d une dette qui
s'envolent ça va très mal finir cette
affaire est ce que rené girard c'est une
finalement un démonstration de plus de
la communautarisation de notre société
ce cette nouvelle initiative est là qu
en fait les gens se reconnaissent -
comme étant des citoyens français que
comme appartenant à une communauté qui
veut être reconnu et éventuellement
plainte ou non
oui c'est la recherche c'est à dire
comme si le bonheur était dans la
victime
je peux pas être heureux de construire
des trains français citoyens qui
m'engagent qui soutient un parti que ce
soit parti communiste qui soutiennent le
ridant la république je les outils qui
s'engage dans la campagne des
républicains
non je il faut que je sois une pour
exister il faut que je sois une victime
c'est une maladie grave dans notre
société qu'il faut qu'il faut étudier
est-ce que c'est dû au fait que cette
société était structurée après la guerre
par deux grands mouvements qui était
l'église catholique et le parti
communiste le progressisme matérialiste
et puis l'église catholique et tout ça a
été ravagé par le consumérisme effréné
que donc en fait il n'ya pas plus rien à
proposer une idéologie de akwa adhéré
comme malek boutih on est au beau jeune
musulman mais on leur propose et on leur
propose d'adhérer à quoi à quelle
société à quelle vision quel avenir de
la france
et v il y avait le patriotisme voilà
mais celui là était aussi assez vaness
ans donc il ya un vrai problème de vie
bhl 2000 culturel est en fait cette
affaire traduit le vide culturel dans
lequel dans lequel on est et christopher
qui nous écoutent pas dans votre sens
puisqu'il dit la télé réalité fait
partie de cette décadence je vous livre
en guise de conclusion une citation de
la philosophe chantal delsol que nous
aimons bien au figaro qu'il y a dit dans
notre monde contemporain
la figure de la victime a remplacé celle
du héros voilà c'est tout pour ce soir
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
été avec nous et point de vue revient
demain même heure même endroit
bien sûr ne zappez pas rester connecté
puisque vous allez suivre maintenant le
focus sur la corée du nord sur les gens
que nous avons parlé tout à l'heure avec
l'analyse de notre spécialiste
isabelle lasserre à 2
[Musique]